video number 10.
thanks for all of you sticking around
we're still finding new things to this
day so if you enjoy this series give
this video a like there is at least one
thing you'll learn with each video
alright let's go
these types of flame pillars burn and
toss link around and can only be walked
through with a full flame break or
outfit but it's actually possible to
sneak through it quickly using a
blizzard rod instead by swinging first
then shield jumping quickly along with
the icy wind you can pass the fire
easily
there have been multiple ways over the
years to permanently keep the one hit
obliterator but what you might not know
is that it has an interesting quirk of
being able to protect you from voiding
out while it's sucking health from you
but this can also be used to let you
fully swim in lava
it's just a little bit spicy so bring
some food with you for a short dip
there's a couple cannons around death
mountain that require you to insert a
remote bomb to shoot it but there is
another way around this by just stuffing
a bomb arrow in the side of the
mechanism you can set it off to fire the
cannonball it might sting a bit though
here are a couple instances of the game
completely freaking out that you might
not have known about if you throw a
luzolpo's arm in pura's lab it tends to
go a little bonkers
you can also head to the coliseum and
push this moblin into the wall corner
with the spin attack they'll start to go
a little nuts as well
and in varuta if you forcefully lodge a
treasure chest between the grates in the
ceiling the whole system collapses and
implodes it might get a little hostile
there are several methods out there to
forcefully drop your master sword so
that another enemy can pick them up
without the use of mods if done
correctly you can have enemies such as
bokoblins lizolfos and maublins pick
them up and use them against you moblins
in particular increase the size of
equipment to fit them so the master
sword and hylian shield look abnormally
larger
most players forget the original
mechanics of the infamous wind bomb the
wind box of the bomb's explosion which
can be useful for things other than just
launching link choo choo jellies can get
a nice boost into an enemy encampment
this way
[Music]
if you ever want to hijack a horse use
deruk's protection and a well-timed
backflip against a charging bokoblin
rider you'll kick them off and steal
their horse mid-charge now that's some
hollywood style action
you've seen a blood moon happen before
but have you ever seen one occur in the
thai flow ruins it looks pretty trippy
if you want some good old 3 stooges
action have some unarmed bokoblins near
a cliff edge hang off the cliff and just
watch the action unfold every attempt
can be different and shows that these
guys are sometimes not the brightest
tool in the shed
there's a section on mount agat in the
gerudo highlands that has an invisible
platform way up in the sky you can hang
out there for as long as you'd like but
most things slide off or fall through
this invisible platform an old trick is
to use a blood moon to make a t-posing
maublin at the beginning of your noble's
quest and it can become a punching bag
for your attacks
crumpling and ragdolling more as you
attack it funny thing is when you look
away it'll transform back into its
normal t-pose
[Music]
breath of the wild never had a prompt to
explain it but pressing the right stick
in will return you to your current
position while on the map screen and it
even has a special sound effect
explosive barrels can be pretty
sensitive to any quick movement as
anything with momentum hitting them will
cause them to explode
but did you know that an enemy's body
moving fast enough into them will also
set them off as well just shoot this
lizalfos from here at the lake tower and
you'll see this in action
the story of the lock-up backroom is
more interesting than you think while
most people may not have even taken a
second glance in this room and just
taken the hylian shield on closer
inspection there are actually chains
dangling from the ceiling
these are chains that were originally
used to lift the center platform into
the room from the area above through
environmental storytelling this shows
that the henox must have been captured
and lifted down into this lockup
backroom and died over time only to
return to life as a stalnox nintendo
even planned to design the upper area
showing the jail grate from above with a
damaged guardian stuck in the metal
grating but for some reason this never
made the final cut even though this
would have been incredibly cool
though you've probably pulled hundreds
if not thousands of bombs during your
playthrough have you actually paid close
attention to how it summoned right from
the beginning of development the bottom
pin of the sheikah slate is meant to be
pulled out and have a bomb appear from
the detached pin you can see the bottom
of the slate to the top of the bomb have
the same pin mechanism
have you ever noticed that the
collection of rocks around shoraha
shrine looked like a crab from above
sand snow and marked paths on the map
don't take shield surf durability but
there's another secret place that
doesn't take durability as well the
rocky dirt and tanagar canyon
for some reason this area just doesn't
take any durability normal rocks still
do though
nintendo put some interesting sub
designs into the making of the divine
beasts if you look closely at baruto's
elephant tail it's actually designed
like an antique water pump making the
tail like the handle
setting an updraft with grass
specifically around a stone peblet for
some reason makes them contemplate the
meaning of life
why are we still here
just to suffer
[Music]
now we've got some more secrets about
some of the final battles which you
might not have known about
during the dark bees ganon fight his
giant laser hurts link pretty bad but
did you know that this laser does half
the damage to your horse this was likely
designed so that would be easier for
players to keep their horse to get
bullet time to attack the weak points
besides the multiple other ways normally
and through glitches to get bullet time
in this battle and how easy this battle
was nintendo really made it hard to fail
here
shock wiz robes and thunder black
ganon's shock balls disarm link while
blocking but a wooden shield can absorb
them instead
fire blight's fire sword during the
second phase isn't just for show it's
actually extremely hot and will light
anything near it on fire this can only
really be shown at the hyrule castle
fire blight fight as balrudania's air is
always burning water blight cannon has a
few interesting quirks its spear swing
attack has a gigantic flurry rush window
allowing link to dodge four times in a
row
and when it does his spear throw attack
it's actually a solid object which means
you have a second to run up or jump on
the spear which is a perfect platform
for some cinematic bullet time
and that's it what was your favorite
thing you learned this time let us know
in the comments below and if you
continue to enjoy new breath of the wild
videos we have a playlist with tons of
stuff we still make to this day and for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
you